[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend die
russische und die ukrainische armee
bereiten sich offenkundig auf eine
gewaltige schlacht um den don was vor
den osten des landes in dem seit acht
jahren ein krieg herrscht von dem viele
im westen und insbesondere in
deutschland glaubten man könne ihnen
irgendwie händeln und einfrieren das hat
sich als grobe fehleinschätzung erwiesen
wie so vieles im umgang mit russland die
unverblümte art in der die ukraine das
der deutschen politik und speziell
bundespräsident steinmeier nun um die
ohren hauen sorgt in berlin zwar für
verärgerung lenkt den blick aber auch
auf das was war nicole diekmann
berichtet
es war der kanzleramtschef frank walter
steinmeier und es war der außenminister
frank walter steinmeier der die deutsche
russlandpolitik
mitverantwortete
es ist der bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier der deshalb jahre später
fehler einräumt einräumen muss putins
angriffskrieg lässt keinen raum für
ausflüchte
das wirklich traurige ist dass wir in
vielen punkten gescheitert sind aber wir
haben es auch mit
unseren unterstützungen etwa bei den
verabredungen abkommen von minsk nicht
geschafft
[Musik]
die entwicklung aufzuhalten
die absage der ukraine ein gewaltiger
frau und deshalb ist es niemand
geringeres als der kanzler der den
bundespräsidenten heute in einem ard
radio interview zur seite springt der
bundespräsident wäre gerne in die
ukraine gefahren und hätte den
präsidenten besucht das ist das
staatsoberhaupt der bundesrepublik
deutschland es ist jedenfalls etwas
irritierend um es höflich zu sagen
nachdem zwei das festhalten am minsker
abkommen der glaube an dialog an eine
partnerschaft mit russland trotz
tschetschenien trotz der annexion der
krim trotz putins unterstützung für
ersatz krieg in syrien experten sprechen
von einer verfehlten politik die sich
nun räche
den vorwurf machen lassen dass er das
stopp schild nicht gesehen hat und auch
nicht darauf reagiert hat und russland
hat einfach weitergemacht ja also
letztlich ist es wirklich eine eine
ignoranz einer einer realität russische
politik und auch von von stopp schildern
die ja den die die irgendwann auch zu
einem und einer anpassung der eigenen
haltung analyse und und auch politik
hätten führen müssen seit gestern also
nun persona non grata in der ukraine dem
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier fällt die politik des
außenministers frank walter steinmeier
auf die füße ralf fücks politik veteran
der grünen war vor gut zwei wochen in
kiew er hat dort zerstörung erlebt
verzweiflung und wut auf die deutsche
politik auf die aktuelle aber auch auf
die der letzten jahre man kann die
person nicht von dem amt trennen frank
walter steinmeier in seiner zeit als
außenminister
einer der architekten
dieser strategische energiepartnerschaft
mit russland schon aus dem 1
dann nord stream 2 wo immer klar war
dass das ein geopolitisches projekt
gegen die ukraine war
hat er bis zum schluss gerechtfertigt
und das haben sich die ukraine natürlich
gemerkt
längst hat das thema die deutsche
innenpolitik erreicht und sorgt für
seltene einigkeit zwischen fdp und der
linken fakt ist dass der ukrainische
präsident meines erachtens einen fehler
gemacht hat es kann nicht darum gehen
alte rechnungen aufzuwärmen ukraine muss
auch begreifen dass bei aller
nach sich die man irgendwann das
tatsächlich für die uns in deutschland
ist und sie eine reise von choice
erschwert habe und ich erleichtert von
einem affront spricht zwar auch der
cdu-chef aber er äußert auch verständnis
offensichtlich sitzen die vorbehalte
gegen die russlandpolitik der spd in
vielen osteuropäischen ländern sehr tief
und das wiederum kann ich gut verstehen
am abend dann im jüdischen museum in
berlin der bundespräsident spricht auf
einer ausstellungseröffnung er redet
auch über den krieg sagt deutschland
stehe fest an der seite der ukraine über
den über seinen persönlichen
diplomatischen eklat aber sagt er kein
wort
unterdessen sind die präsidenten von
polen und den baltischen staaten in der
ukraine angekommen ohne den
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier
michael roters und zugeschaltet
spd-außenpolitiker vorsitzender des
auswärtigen ausschusses des bundestags
und heute selbst erst von einer ukraine
reise zurückgekehrt guten abend herr
roth guten abend france locker wenn man
das letzte bild sich doch mal so ansieht
die polen und die drei balten und die
polen sind nun quasi alleine nach kiew
gereist ohne die deutschen ist da auch
ein stück symbolbild dabei dann halt
ohne deutschland
ich habe gestern mit meiner kollegin
marie agnes strack zimmermann und mit
meinem kollegen toni hofreiter
gespürt wie wichtig es den ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer ist sich vor ort einen
eindruck zu verschaffen was krieg
wirklich bedeutet und ich habe
inzwischen eine ahnung davon was es
bedeutet tagtäglich angst zu haben um
das eigene leben tagtäglich angst zu
haben um das leben der liebsten nicht
mehr zu wissen wie es weiter geht und
diese angst die hat sich dort fest
gefressen und festgesetzt insofern bin
ich jetzt kein freund davon dieser
deutschen selbstbespiegelung es dreht
sich momentan nicht alleine um uns ja
wir müssen uns prüfen wir haben für
diese ausnahme situation keinen
masterplan keine blaupause in der
schublade aber leute der krieg findet in
der ukraine statt dort ist ja extrem
ausnahmezustand die ukraine würde sich
von deutschland die nächsten und die
ukraine würde sich von deutschland sehr
viel mehr unterstützung wünschen deshalb
noch mal die frage droht deutschland
sich hier innerhalb europas vor allen
dingen gegenüber osteuropa und auch den
balken zu isolieren
ich habe gestern viel anerkennung und
auch dankbarkeit gespürt über das was
wir bereits geleistet haben es gibt
immens hohe erwartungshaltung an
deutschland als großes und wichtiges
land im herzen der europäischen union
als wichtiges land auch in der nato aber
wir können wir müssen mehr tun die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer haben
wahnsinnige angst vor dieser neuen
militärischen offensive im osten der
ukraine die möglicherweise alles in den
schatten zu stellen droht was wir an
grauenhaften bereits erlebt haben und
deshalb gibt es die forderung
beispielsweise nach schweren waffen
damit man sich noch besser zu
verteidigen vermag und ich finde wir
müssen darauf rasch eine
verantwortungsbewusste antwort finden
gemeinsam mit unseren partnerinnen und
partner also würde die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer auch spüren wir tragen nicht
bedenken vor uns her wir wägen selbst
handelte sich gleichwohl werden
herausragen herbert wir wir handeln auch
ich bin für rasche entscheidungen
und wir brauchen jetzt pragmatische
lösungen damit auch die waffen die die
ukraine benötigt die sie zur
verteidigung braucht sicher und schnell
und hand auch in die ukraine kommen die
mit ihrem mitgereiste frau strack
zimmermann vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses hat deutliche
kritik an bundeskanzler gesagt da wird
nicht geführt ja es wird nicht gehandelt
eben während die russen auf den don was
zu marschieren wird im kanzleramt immer
noch abgewartet
wir brauchen jetzt eine entscheidung und
deutschland hat eine ganze menge
geleistet aber noch einmal es ist jetzt
noch mal eine verschärfung der
dramatischen lage in der ukraine
eingetreten und ich werde einen satz
einer kollegin des ukrainischen
parlamentes nicht vergessen die hat uns
gesagt die beste humanitäre hilfe die
ihr zu leisten vermögen sind derzeit
waffen die wir brauchen damit wir aus
einer position der wehrhaftigkeit und
der stärke diesen furchtbaren krieg
werden beenden können das mag vielen als
eine zumutung erscheinen aber wir müssen
das ernstnehmen und deswegen braucht die
ukraine jetzt mehr unterstützung von
deutschland aber auch von anderen
partnern diese in der nato und in der eu
diese zumutung von der sie sprachen
meinen sie damit vielleicht auch vor
allen den kollegen aus ihren eigenen
reihen innerhalb der spd die eben diese
zeitenwende die scholz erstmal verbal
eingeläutet hat eigentlich nicht so
recht mit gehen sondern lieber auf
verhandlungen mit putin setzen und das
mit diesem schweren waffen eigentlich
nicht wollen ich erlebe viel
unsicherheit in unserer gesellschaft ich
erlebe einerseits ganz viel solidarität
von menschen die auch sagen jetzt müsst
ihr wirklich noch weitergehen wir wissen
wie schwierig das ist es gibt aber auch
menschen die machen sich sorgen die
haben angst vor einem dritten weltkrieg
die haben angst davor dass putin zu
atomwaffen greift die haben angst davor
dass sie irgendwann ihre heizkosten
nicht mehr bezahlen können und ich finde
wir müssen jetzt als politikerinnen und
politiker orientierung geben in diesen
zeiten die für uns allen die uns allen
etwas abverlangen aber sie verlangen vor
allem den menschen in der ukraine etwas
ab denn die erleben tagtäglich was krieg
wirklich bedeutet und wann fängt olaf
scholz an die bevölkerung davon zu
überzeugen den übrigen mehrheitlich
längst dafür ist schwere waffen zu
liefern
wir haben ja einen erhellenden moment
und einen moment der führung und der
orientierung erlebt wenige tage nach dem
ausbruch dieses russischen
angriffskriege aber dass der
regierungserklärung des senders marder
panzer oder ähnliches richtung ukraine
gerollt das ist ja das was präsident
selensky will und er sagt es ganz
konkret mit typen nummern was wir von
den deutschen wollen sie haben auf ihrer
reise ja auch echte listen vorgelegt
bekommen warum sagt denn eigentlich frau
lamprecht bundesverteidigungsministerium
immer noch das müsse man alles geheim
halten und das wollten auch die ukraine
dass das geheim gehalten wird das passt
doch irgendwie nicht zusammen
ich bin dafür dass wir das jetzt tun und
ich habe auch meine meinung geändert wie
im übrigen in den vergangenen wochen
öfter meine meinung geändert habe auch
ich war mal sehr zurückhaltend was
waffenlieferungen anbelangt aber ich
sehe jetzt die konkrete bedrohung von
putin ich sehe wozu diese russische
armee bereit und in der lage ist und
deshalb trage ich nach abwägung aller
allen fürs und wieder die entscheidung
und die forderung mit dass wir jetzt
auch schwere waffen liefern und wenn wir
sie nicht haben dann haben sie
möglicherweise andere partner in
mittelosteuropa die können wir dann
wiederum mit neuem material unterstützen
denn es geht ja darum dass dieses
material dass diese schweren waffen auch
jetzt eingesetzt werden können nun nicht
erst in einem vierteljahr herr roth
danke für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
nachher im heute-journal update gibt es
dann ein interview mit der vorsitzenden
des verteidigungsausschusses marie agnes
strack zimmermann von der fdp die wie
gerade eben schon gesagt zuletzt
deutliche kritik richtung kanzleramt
formuliert hatte
zu den vielen nebenwirkungen dieses
krieges gehört dass sich die nato mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit bald nach
norden erweitert finnland und schlägen
könnten schon in wenigen wochen die
mitgliedschaft beantragen in beiden
ländern läuft dazu eine intensive
debatte und die nato würde beide eu
länder auch mit offenen armen empfangen
womit neben bei einer von vielen
gravierenden unterschieden zwischen der
nato und der sogenannten einflusssphäre
russlands deutlich wird um einen
beitritt zur nato bewirbt man sich
freiwillig weil man schutz sucht
russland hingegen übt zwang aus und wir
jemand schert aus siehe georgien die
ukraine ihr kriegt dort könnte nun die
skandinavischen nachbarn in die arme der
nato bleiben heike groos errichtet
zwischen uns passt kein wird so auch die
optische botschaft in stockholm heute
ministerpräsidentin magdalene anders
empfinden ihre finnische nachbarin und
amtskollegin st anna marie die beiden
regierungschefinnen bewegt momentan nur
eine frage nato-beitritt ja oder nein
wir müssen das wirklich herausfinden was
ist das beste für mich nun für unsere
sicherheit da unseren frieden in dieser
neuen situation natürlich ist es für uns
wichtig die aktuelle diskussionen führt
solche verfolgen deshalb sind wir in
einem sehr engen austausch kontakt 700
millionen euro mehr für verteidigung nur
in diesem jahr recht finnland voran
richtung nato ihnen der artikel 5 des
nato-vertrags garantiert dass wenn ein
mitgliedsland angegriffen wird andere
mitglieder ist verteidigung und
natürlich sorgte der noch erwarten
schirm auch dafür dass wir sicherheit
hätten aber es gibt unterschiedliche
sichtweisen den beitritt beantragen oder
nicht wir müssen das alles sehr
gründlich
analysieren
finnlands nachbar schweden zeigt seit
wochen militärpräsenz im eigenen land
wie hier auf der insel gotland eine
warnung an russland soll das sein das
muskelspiel der schwedischen armee stößt
aber nicht nur auf begeisterung die
hälfte der menschen ist gegen einen
antrag ihres landes auf nato
mitgliedschaft
wir gehörten 200 jahre zu keiner
militärischen allianz und das hat uns
gut getan ich denke das ist eine richtig
schlechte um die eine allianz von
atommächten
ich finde nicht dass wir mit ließ werden
sollten
wir konnten uns noch nie auf unseren
großen nachbarn verlassen noch niemals
ja es fühlt sich richtig an dass sowohl
schweden als auch finnland beitreten in
finnland erhielt heute das parlament ein
bericht der regierung als
diskussionsgrundlage eine art für und
wider nato-beitritt aber ohne jede
empfehlung laut umfragen sind 70 prozent
finden dafür die militärische
neutralität aufzugeben ein enormer
zuwachs anfang des jahres waren es nur
grad erinnerung schon 1990 er jahren war
hier finden unterstützen schon immer die
außenpolitik der eu und die sanktions ja
wir werden überlegen vermutlich leben
wir in den nächsten jahren in einer
eiszeit was die beziehungen von finnland
zu russland angehen aber klar russland
bleibt immer unser nachbar von nebenan
so nennt man diese haltung in finnland
niemals aufgeben für sein anliegen ein
stehen trotz ständiger russischer
drohungen es bleibt den beiden ländern
eine schwere entscheidung aber finnland
und schweden wollen sie noch in diesem
frühjahr fällen
die ukraine wünschte sie hätte die
gleiche option gehabt für die beiden
skandinavischen ländern ihr bleibt jetzt
nur bei der nato weiter um hilfe zu
bitten und mit dem krieg in der ukraine
beginnt jetzt auch die nachrichten von
heinz wolf us präsident biden hat dem
russischen präsidenten putin vorgeworfen
in der ukraine völkermord zu beginn
heute wurde in einem käfer vor ort ein
weiteres massengrab gefunden insgesamt
wurden in borodjanka und butscher
inzwischen mehr als
720 leichen geborgen 200 menschen werden
noch vermisst
russland setzte seine angriffe im osten
und süden der ukraine ford in kharkiv
wurde ein mehrstöckiges wohnhaus
getroffen in mario pohl haben sich nach
angaben russland ukrainische soldaten
ergeben präsident selensky gab heute
eine konkrete liste von schweren waffen
bekannt die sein land brauche um eine
mögliche russische großoffensive im
osten abwehren zu können
das bundeskabinett hat die kräftigste
rentenerhöhung seit jahrzehnten
beschlossen demnach steigt zum ersten
juli die rente im osten um mehr als
sechs prozent im westen gibt es gut fünf
prozent mehr auch die
erwerbsminderungsrente soll angehoben
werden
2024 um bis zu 7,5 prozent sie soll
menschen helfen die krankheitsbedingt
nicht mehr oder nur eingeschränkt
arbeiten können
nach den schüssen in der new yorker u
bahn gestern ist ein verdächtiger
festgenommen worden ein 62-jähriger mann
nach dem gefahndet worden war der täter
hatte in der u-bahn im stadtteil
brooklyn um sich geschossen und mehrere
menschen verletzt
nach den schweren überschwemmungen in
südafrika ist die zahl der todesopfer
auf mehr als 250 gestiegen zahlreiche
menschen werden noch vermisst zur
katastrophenhilfe wurde auch das militär
mobilisiert die bergungsarbeiten
gestalten sich schwierig da viele
straßen weggespült und brücken von den
wassermassen eingerissen worden
tagelange starkregen hatte und in der
küstenstadt durban und der umliegenden
provinz chaos und zerstörung ausgelöst
der hafen in durban musste vorübergehend
geschlossen werden
für die korona pandemie gilt weiterhin
die höchste warnstufe der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
die whu schloss sich der empfehlung
unabhängiger experten an die sich
dagegen ausgesprochen hatten die anfangs
2020 erklärte gesundheitliche notlage
von internationaler tragweite
aufzuheben der blick auf die korona
zahlen in deutschland die sieben tage
incidents geht laut robert koch institut
weiter zurück auf jetzt 1000
44,7 das lka hat 176 1303 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden gemeldet 38
1682 weniger als vergangenen mittwoch
361 todesfälle kamen hinzu
dass emanuel makro im ersten wahlgang
der französischen präsidentschaftswahl
vor seiner konkurrentin marie le pen lag
hat den großen teilen europas erstmal
für erleichterung gesorgt
die sorge ist groß dass in der jetzigen
situation eine französische präsident in
das ruder übernimmt die ihre radikale
wählerschaft befriedigen muss und ihre
nähe zu moskau in der vergangenheit gar
nicht erst zur mental versuchte im kreml
würde jedenfalls krimsekt fließen
deutschland hingegen würde seinen
wichtigsten europäischen verbündeten
verlieren für die eu als ganzes wäre es
nach dem wechsel ein zweiter schlag der
europa auch militärisch entscheidend
schwächen könnte die stichwahl ist am
übernächsten sonntag thomas walde
berichtet aus paris
tomaten 595 das kilo und zwei euro für
eine gurke
gucken sie mal der ankauf die preise
steigen wer einkauft stellt fest dass
man für dasselbe geld viel weniger
bekommt das spüren die menschen ganz
konkret im alltag
letzte woche kostete das küchenpapier 10
euro diese woche 15 euro alles steigt
nur die gehälter nicht
kaufkraft wird frankreichs wahl
entscheiden kaufkraft das wort der
stunde die arbeitslosigkeit ist in
emanuel macros amtszeit gesunken aber
viele haben nichts davon dass mittlere
einkommen liegt unter 1800 euro im monat
in dieser zweiten runde des wahlkampfes
geht es vor allem um die die wenig geld
und bisher links gewählt haben marine le
pen zielt ganz auf die arbeiterschaft
und die abgehängten sie will etliche
steuern senken oder ganz abschaffen etwa
auf viele lebensmittel schuld an der
misere sei der präsident musste auch die
lage gerät außer kontrolle
mir macht sorgen dass der präsident so
tut als würde er das nicht sehen
dabei verfolgt das thema emanuel makro
auf schritt und tritt erreicht durch das
land um sich dem sozialen ärger
auszusetzen damit die menschen jetzt
dampf ablassen und nicht an der wahlurne
die menschen sind arm und können ihre
miete und ihr brot com bezahlen es gibt
not die menschen fühlen sich von ihnen
alleingelassen
nein das stimmt so faktisch nicht ich
habe in meiner amtszeit die mindestrente
und die beihilfen erhöht
gestern abend in straßburg wollte man
den bogen nach europa schlagen makro ist
so proeuropäisch dass er zu hause unter
rechtfertigungsdruck gerät
es gemüse bei allem respekt sind sie
erst europäer und dann erst franzose ich
bin franzose patriot und europäer
die nationalisten marine le pen markiert
auch hier dem gegen punkt für probleme
in europa machte sie heute nachmittag
vor allem ein land verantwortlich wir
sind opfer deutscher entscheidungen ich
lasse deutschen endlich die französische
atomwirtschaft zerstören der deutsch
französische motor in europa ist eine
fiktion
kritik an wladimir putin gab es auch
allerdings nur von einer demonstrantin
die schnell überwältigt wurde in
umfragen liegt le pen derzeit hinter
makro aber nur knapp
ein teil der wählerschaft ist nicht
motiviert und könnte sich im zweiten
wahlgang der stimme enthalten auf der
anderen seite geht es weder die sehr
wütend und hochmotiviert sind man kann
nicht mehr ausschließen dass marie le
pen tatsächlich präsidentin der republik
wird
es beginnt im portemonnaie und endet bei
der zukunft europas frankreichs
zerrissene wählerschaft hat noch elf
tage sich zu entscheiden
und jetzt nochmal eins mit wirtschaft
führende wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute
haben heute ihre gemeinsame frühjahrs
konjunkturprognose vorgelegt auch sie
erwarten für deutschland nun deutlich
weniger wachstum als noch in der
prognose im vergangenen herbst sina
mainitz wie sind die erwartungen im
einzelnen bescheiden denn ging es im
herbst in den wirtschaftsprognosen für
dieses jahr nur um die pandemie geht es
nun kurz vor ostern zusätzlich noch um
energie und steigende preise diese
düsteren konjunkturaussichten wollen
einfach nicht abreißen
führende wirtschaftsinstitute haben ihre
aussichten heute deutlich nach unten
korrigiert von 4,8 prozent wachstum auf
nun nur noch 2,7 prozent auch die hohe
inflation sorgt die forscher sie steigt
auf 6,1 prozent dieses jahr und wäre
damit so hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht
mehr
ökonomen raten dem staat das geld nicht
nach dem gießkannenprinzip auszuschütten
opulente geldgeschenke könnten diese
lage noch verschlimmern werden solche
hilfen auf breiter front ausgereicht
treibt das zusätzlich die inflation und
torpediert den wichtigen lenkungseffekt
höherer energiepreise heißt es im falle
eines lieferstopps für russische energie
wird nicht nur mit noch höheren preisen
sondern auch mit einer rezession kommen
das jahr gerechnet in diesem fall
stünden dann 220 milliarden euro an
wirtschaftsleistung im feuer kein wunder
dass sich der deutsche aktienmarkt am
abend saft und kraftlos zeigt der dax
beendet den handel mit einem stand von
14.000 76 zählern
rezessionsängste steigende preise
lieferengpässe anhaltender krieg da
fehlt einfach die leichtigkeit der
anleger am aktienmarkt sind am 1 vielen
dank
die deutsche handball nationalmannschaft
hat den ersten schritt zur qualifikation
für die wm 2022 gemacht durch ein 34 26
gegen die färöer am abend in kiel das
rückspiel findet am samstag statt und
ist live auf zdf de zu sehen und jetzt
die zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
27 22 29 42 46 die superzahl 2 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
seltsam im nebel zu wandern das berühmte
hermann hesses gedicht mag den besuchern
im münchner haus der kunst in den sinn
kommen wenn sie dort im dampf der klüfte
durch nebel dürfte wandeln käme auf
goethe dazu durch die fulminante
ausstellung der japanischen künstlerin
lucy koh naka ja sie bietet ein
einzigartiges kunsterlebnis
betörend sagt unsere autorin barbara
lueg und schwer zu beschreiben besser
man sieht es sich an
[Musik]
was entsteht wenn alles kommt und was
bleibt wenn alles geht
kunst in bewegung wie das leben selbst
das ist ein traum weil der kunst soll
irgendwie lebendig sein und soll immer
berühren und diese kunst berührt sich
und berührt uns und das glaube dass
wichtiger und das macht mich sehr auch
sehr emotional
fuji kona kaya entdeckte nebel als
kunstform sehr früh ihr vater ein
berühmter physiker nimmt sie mit in die
berge er will ihr zeigen wie sich die
welt verändert was fu chi kuo dort
erlebt lässt sie nie mehr los
[Musik]
wir sahen wie sich die wolken am
horizont in niebel verwandelt
die ganze landschaft wurde weiß
es war atemberaubend
hypnotisierend ich habe zeit und raum
völlig vergessen
[Musik]
seither betört makaya mit ihrem
wabernden skulpturen menschen auf der
ganzen welt
[Musik]
es ist ein erleben erfüllen ertasten ein
verschmelzen mit dem kunstwerk selbst
[Musik]
also wurde nur diese nebelwand auf uns
zukommen ist wie so ein ja wieso ein
festes etwas aber dann war das einfach
an uns vorbeigezogen ist ja ich finde es
faszinierend was macht orientierungslos
man ist so in dieser nebelwand fangen
auch weil man nebel kennt aber es ist
irgendetwas ganz anderer ist und es war
wie als hätte man so ein schleier vor
den augen aber es war halt real als war
echt cool die ausstellung zeigt mag als
reale nebel welten videos ihrer
weltweiten inszenierungen aber auch ihre
akribischen berechnungen und fragen im
vorfeld kann ich nebelwolken lenken
welchen einfluss wird der wind haben mit
ihrem sehr frühen ökologischen
bewusstsein seit den 70ern war sie ihrer
zeit als künstlerin und mensch weit
voraus ich glaube da sind die nebels
geturnt visionär sind weil sie unsere
verwobenheit unsere vernetzung mit
unserer umwelt vorweg denkt und das ist
glaube ich das was ihre arbeit heute
wichtig macht
so ist ihre kunst auch ein plädoyer für
nachhaltigkeit für die flüchtigkeit der
dinge und all das mit wasser und luft
das war schon heute sind wir gleich geht
es weiter mit dem zweiten teil unseres
neuen zdf format don't stop the music
und gegen 0.45 gibt es dann unser heute
schon ein update mit wulf schmiese an
diesem morgen wieder darauf wieder sind
wieder sind
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine front hatte
uns erreicht und bringt einige schauer
und gewitter morgen im tagesverlauf in
der nacht überquert sie uns schon
bereits südostwärts ja unter vor ist es
ruhig und dahinter auch dieser front hat
ist relativ schwierig zwischen den zwei
hochs und das ganze verläuft eben sehr
langsam scheinen die nacht und da liegt
die front einmal quer über deutschland
mit regen davor ist es ruhig dahinter
ebenfalls und die temperaturen sinken
dabei auf 4 bis 7 grad im südosten
deutschlands sonst auf 11 grad zum
beispiel in der mitte und richtung
westen morgen im tagesverlauf also mehr
schauer und gewitter die allmählich
südostwärts ziehen und die können auch
vereinzelt auch mal kräftiger ausfallen
davor ist es ruhig und dahinter
ebenfalls da gibt es zwar viele wolken
aber hin und wieder zeigt sich dann auch
die sonne bei höchsten temperaturen bis
22 grad vorderfront und 12 bis 15 grad
an den küsten aber allgemein wird es
doch noch einmal richtig warm bei 17 bis
21 grad ja und die nächsten tage
karfreitag vor allem nach osten hin und
im süden einzelne schauer vor allem im
nordosten deutlich kühler als im
südwesten 8 bis 21 grad ist die
temperaturspanne ja und am samstag ist
es größtenteils trocken im norden viel
sonnenschein bei neun bis 18 grad und
damit ein schöner ab